THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
UNTIL THE END OF THE MONTH TO
DECIDE WHETHER TO ASK THAT
QUESTION.
HERE'S MORE TONIGHT FROM LOS
ANGELES.
>> YOU CAN'T KNOW YOUR COUNTRY
UNLESS YOUR COUNTRY KNOWS YOU.
>> A SIMPLE PROPOSITION
CONTROVERSIAL.
>> IT'S THE MARGINALIZED
POPULATION THAT WE NEED TO GET
TO COOPERATE TO GET COUNTED.
>> FROM CONGRESS TO THE COURTS,
DEMOCRATS WANT ONE QUESTION
REMOVED FROM THE NEXT CENSUS:
ARE YOU A U.S. CITIZEN?
>> ADDING A CITIZENSHIP QUESTION
WILL MAKE THE CENSUS LESS
ACCURATE BECAUSE MORE PEOPLE
WILL HAVE FEAR OF FILLING IT
OUT.
>> THE CENSUS IS NOT JUST A HEAD
COUNT.
IT'S A SNAPSHOT OF AMERICA.
>> PRIOR TO 1950 THE SURVEY
ASKED RESIDENTS IF THEY WERE
CITIZENS.
AN ATTEMPT TO REINSTATE THE GE
AN ATTEMPT TO REINSTATE THE G
GE -- QUESTION IS DRAWING FIRE.
HOW THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
SCHEME THREATENS AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY, ERIC HOLDER ARGUES
THE PRESIDENT IS USING THE
QUESTION TO SCARE MINORITIES.
ROBBING BLUE STATES IN THE
REDISTRICTING.
THE CENSUS DETERMINES HOW MANY
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS EACH STATE
RECEIVES AND HOW FEDERAL FUNDS
ARE DISTRIBUTED.
>> SHOULD WE INCLUDE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY FOR
REPRESENTATION?
NO, WE SHOULD NOT.
>> 1 IN 6 HOUSEHOLDS ARE ASKED
THE QUESTION ON THE LONG FALL